talks between the u.s. and the Taliban
are dead at least for the time being
following Donald Trump's surprise
cancellation of a secret summit with
Taliban leaders at the president's
retreat at Camp David we've made real
progress and then the Taliban failed to
live up to a series of commitments that
they had made and when that happened
President Trump said I'm not going to
take that deal I'm not going to work
with someone that can't deliver on their
commitments Pompeyo also said the US
special envoy for Afghanistan is being
recalled and he warned that things are
about to get worse
for the Taliban after fighters took
responsibility for a suicide bomb attack
that killed 12 people in Kabul last week
including a US soldier Trump's national
security adviser John Bolton and
Republican Party politicians have been
dubious about the nearly year-long
negotiations hosted by Qatar saying
Taliban leaders are not to be trusted
it doesn't seem to get better but I'm
sure it will get worse if we leave
frankly I think backing away from where
we were just dealing with the Taliban is
the right thing to do leaving troops
there for right now is the right thing
to do Democrats criticized Trump's
negotiating style saying he doesn't take
advice from experts that our president
isn't listening to his generals to his
diplomats to the intelligence community
frankly that's largely why
general mattis for whom I have huge
respect resigned in protest was our
president's tendency to make abrupt
decisions without knowing the context or
the region and without relying on the
advice of the skilled diplomats and
generals we have Trump has promised to
withdraw around 14,000 US troops based
in Afghanistan failure to fulfill that
pledge could have adverse political
consequences in the presidential
election a little over a year from now
whether the talks are truly dead remains
to be seen Pompeyo noted that Trump has
employed similar tactics before only to
resume negotiations later he walked away
in Hanoi from North Koreans when they
wouldn't do a deal that made sense for
America he'll do that with Iranians when
the Chinese moved away from the trade
agreement with the talks on hold the
longest war in US history will continue
to drag on
approximately 2400 US service members
have died in Afghanistan since 2001 and
more than 100,000 Afghan civilians
soldiers and fighters have lost their
lives rob reynolds al jazeera Washington